yes 42 is it now 42 and to mantus are
you being sneaky and by sneaky I mean
are you guessing more than two no you're
not just double checking and double
check in wonderful let's go challenge
three standard invite let's roll another
tournament happening soon and thanks
again for those of you who continue to
retweet the stream that I posted to my
Twitter account so let's get this kicked
off d for for the win night out this is
um have to go quicker right I have to
remember that this is not a five-minute
one now is it let's try this this is
different I would normally just play a
four but um not now huh um I'm going to
get beat up if I try f3 and e4 let me
just make sure I could get that pond
back and maybe it's g3 then I'm supposed
to going with here what's the what's the
move actually I'm gonna try this I think
I put I'm having flashbacks of a game
that I played a real long while ago
where I played this in it got really
really messy so and I think I ran with f
three in that game I just try it I'm
going to try it i think c5 is a good
move here or no maybe not you have to be
cautious is f3 move because sometimes
there's like if my bishop wasn't out
here there's a sack and then stuff over
like um against my king the Queen now th
for soap on push night takes takes
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes Queen
it's a little scary
I'm going to come all the way back to
avoid that tactic and now i'm just
looking to play here next and i think i
will have established a good center now
what if b5 ok now i don't know that i
have to really react to that although
maybe I should play night here avoid
exchanges seeing that I'm gonna have a
space advantage am I going a bit too
astray if I do that just going to do
this because i'm pretty sure it's good
hit the bishop I'm hitting I'm guarding
my night and maybe maybe on second
thought maybe on my next move will do
this I just want to be sure that I get
this move in and these since I just
control over this square what's going to
be the scoop it's difficult for black to
be making use of that of course right so
what else are they thinking of either
react right away or actually take here
first okay so i'm going to i'm going to
try i'm actually going to try that maybe
could reposition to be three and watch
out for the c5 advance is the Queen
going to defend or is the rook if the
RIP defends I might have Bishop to g3
winning some material so now I think I
need some more development so let me do
that and I don't to worry about a night
move hitting my night anymore but there
might be Bishop here ok and there it is
so now at least I'm getting ready to get
to see five one day I might want to
throw a question the bishop come back to
a five or even go to c5 I want to watch
out for both pawn breaks I think this
structure right here is really negating
both night and bishop and even this
night in some sense because I have
control of receipt for with my bishop
and d5 with this efore pawn a three
castle these are definitely candidate
moves and that I did not expect ok this
is getting crazy maybe it's the best
practical decision and hopefully this is
working out right here I want to hit the
night be very forceful here and
hopefully i get castle before it is too
late so rook f1 and King to g1 is coming
up so let's let this rook do that let's
let this rook do that you follow that
one so I'm ready to sneak my king away
and
what do you want to do here what do you
want to do I really want to deal with
the night right there I think it's
actually okay a little scary but I want
to focus on this square i think if i
captured that's it's too nice of a
structure for black so let's not and say
we did on that one there under a minute
if night f4 I could play here I could
lose my bishop but I have two nights
hopefully they find good squares or
maybe even here whoa that'd be pretty
slick night f4 Queen here and actually
before it's too late let's get out of
any nonsense now my rook is guarding
that and was missed oh that was a that
was a goof right okay let's just make
sure of the time situation and i'm going
to play here just so that there's no
crazy tricks on this at this point right
here so let me give a check and then
take otherwise would be Bishop check
here and looking to just double double
drugs double trouble my Knights need
some help actually I need to defend
against that and I think I want to allow
my queen to do it actually I don't want
to move any ponds just yet and this it
can't be chased away really because I'm
on this and just can't be easy can it um
what's the scoop here okay I think I
need to back up
wow this is a little scary actually or a
lot scary okay wait I guess I have to do
this Souza this is tough ok my night has
a good square and there's no more threat
against my king right just defend here I
want to defend everything come on go
move ok um he's got to go he's got to go
mm I have this I have a covered
frightened all right I don't have any
time oh I'm getting mated oh man ah good
game that was bad ah that's a tough one
stomach oh I don't want to stomach that
one me back up I don't have much time to
go over it either cuz that term is too
coming up so that's not a good one to
start off with going in that tournament
oh man ah even being up a piece now wait
let me back up because let me make this
right here very clear I think that this
is a good idea Black is showing what a
good sense that this is an asset and you
might as well enter a position where
there's some imbalance instead of
entering a position in other words where
you kind of ground down right so take
note of the decision that black played
right here it's showing a good sense of
a good sense of the position I thought
that that was a really good practical
decision by black so I think I think
white is better in that position so I'm
wondering where there's an improvement
maybe something tells me I mean is there
some quick like be pot be 5 b-4 pawn
advances um what else f3 h6 yeah I don't
know okay we'll wait something needs to
be done like I think I'm really I'm
really comfortable right here like if
there isn't something soon like should
see five be played right now I wonder I
don't know I'm enough to play around a
bit more with this this is just just
because
I lost doesn't mean I wouldn't go back
into this of course there was I did have
a good good position but where is there
something more maybe black could be
doing because um I lost track of time to
it towards the end right there I should
have been doing time burners I should
have started at I'm burning a trick
sooner but that wasn't happening was it
um I don't know where is there an
improvement for black I think it's uh
where is it starting at two minutes that
tournament I'm not quite sure maybe
right here c5 I think maybe see 5 or
b-five beef or something like that I
don't know if I have any worries after
the Knight b6 move so it's again i'm
thinking right here on this move move
number move number 10 maybe there's an
adjustment on the on the black side
right i was up at peace no i was up to
pieces haha i'm up to pieces oh can you
believe it believe it happened and it
will continue to happen okay let's close
out and let me track that tournament
down is starting very very very